but getting outside your comfort zone is
is also a good thing and
I never thought my belief in that would
lead me into something like this but um
as as strange it is as it is to say and
probably to hear I'm grateful uh that
you know the Lord has put this
opportunity in front of me because
I can only go forward and and hopefully
glorify him in the process
that's awesome I will say that you do
have the Adam Sandler Zohan look though
I know that look that's a legit look I
can't get it out of my head right now
that's all I'm thinking about with the
hair doing all this stuff Got A Few Good
Men and we got this off yeah so you want
to just show the picture I mean there is
an element of a little bit of Zohan
stuff going on there it's a good looking
guy okay